[Music]
happy birthday Prince William he turns
36 yes it certainly does future king
continuing his priestly duties today and
revealing how he wants to major dad
points with four-year-old son George
today rather than celebrating his
birthday at home with his family the
prince was opening a Center for injured
servicemembers during his speech he
joked about little George's love of
construction sites along the way I have
demolished the building George was at an
age at the time that he loved seeing the
[ __ ] in action so did my street cred as
a father of a world of good today
William's grandmother the Queen
presented trophies at the Royal Ascot
horse races in attendance and I fell
apart of a crust Wilson and his wife
Sierra both donned the traditional
attire including a top hat for him and a
fascinator for her earlier this week
when Harry and Megan participated at the
races William was in Liverpool opening
immense mental health center the future
King has a heavy royal schedule on
Sunday he will begin a trip to Israel
and Jordan Kate will remain home with
their three kids while she's still
officially on maternity leave the next
big event for Kate's is the christening
of baby Prince Louie on Monday July 9
Britain is abuzz over whether his aunt
Duchess Megan will be named as one of
his godmothers in a royal throwback
Thursday while William and Harry looked
at home movies of Harry's 1984
christening William couldn't help but
give his brother a fig about his
baptismal gown hassel if you're a boy or
girl about to dress thank you happens at
this stage of your life you don't really
have a decision where he looks great in
blue the dress that I'm him
[Music]